this is global toronto
global news at six starts right now
you are looking at a live shot over
bluer street and avenue road where
thousands of truckers converge today to
spread their message of frustration over
covet 19 vaccine mandates and
restrictions
truckers from all across the greater
toronto area met this morning in a
number of locations before making their
way downtown for their protest which has
caused chaos on toronto's streets and
surrounding highways
good evening and thanks for joining us
tonight i'm mark carcasol and today's
protest at queen's park did not turn out
as expected thousands of demonstrators
showed up but they were not able to
drive to the legislature because the
roads had been blocked by police let's
go live now to global shaun o'shea who
has been in the thick of things all day
sean phillison on what's been taking
place today
mark good evening you're right thousands
of people did in fact show up here today
there were thousands indeed the trucks
though could not get through they
couldn't get through here because police
had shut down all the roads leading to
queen's park where we are right now at
queen's park circle and grosvenor but
the protesters were here and they gave
their message
do you take your freedom back
i get to choose what goes in my body not
you not the mainstream media okay
freedom right here
protesters making their point like this
man carrying an oversized syringe yeah
this booster is for justin trudeau
trudeau's been vaccinated three times
he's got cove that should tell you
what's happening or the man with the
large mask this is what the future is
going to look like
what was supposed to be a protest convoy
of trucks at queen's park couldn't get
here as originally planned road
restrictions prevented that although
some trucks and supporters made it to
avenue road and bloor street police told
truckers they could get together far
away from downtown toronto and they did
in shopping mall parking lots it left
most protesters opposing vaccination
mandates to make the trip here on foot
going too far has its extreme
consequences we see that now they
expressed doubt about the value of
vaccinations proven by medical science
to reduce deaths and serious illness
from covet but if these public health
measures were effective as they're being
told to we would see bigger effects in
the data those supporting vaccinations
were here too everybody cares about the
same thing people want to see health
care being delivered when it's needed
where it's needed counter protesters
came to support health care workers
there are definitely some very rigid
opinions
maybe i have one too but i feel like i'm
listening to public health experts some
on both sides faced off this type of
protest occurs to me as part of a
problem not part of the solution science
they say is what to follow beyond
internet guy typing furiously and
getting angry everybody just wants
angry peace again in evidence here this
man calling for journalists to be put on
trial and killed after your convictions
your executions cannot come soon enough
you are the enemy of the people you're
the vile liars the message is you guys
are the problem
anti-media anti-government eddie
mandates three pillars of these
protesters who succeeded to get their
message out but for the most part not
getting their trucks in
so many uniformed and non-uniform police
officers here on the streets all around
queen's park but just one arrest the 22
year old was arrested in the northern
part of queen's park just north of the
legislative building and he was charged
with three charges including assault
mark
sean you were at the protests last
weekend in ottawa which are going on for
a second weekend now and have spread out
to other cities like toronto and others
around the country how does the the
gathering in toronto today compared to
last week's in ottawa
similarities mark you know festive uh
kind of party-like in ottawa and here
today uh for the most part but as you
can hear probably in the background a
lot of people
yelling various expletives at the media
which was going on all day but the
reality is that um
are you gonna lie again and that you're
getting a pretty good sense of what
people were saying all day here so
people trying to get their message
across
vaccinations
and we listened and we broadcast what
they had to say but what you're hearing
is it doesn't matter what you say it
doesn't matter what your report this is
what you get from people at this protest
today mark
all right that's global shawn o'shea
reporting live at queen's park tonight
thanks for doing your job sean
today's protest impacted businesses
emergency runs to hospitals even forced
the closure of some streets and this has
upset many around the city global's
morgan campbell is live on bloor street
with that side of the story tonight
morgan
well mark i'm here at bloor and bedford
and you can actually see right here
behind me some transport trucks are
parked there's been just continuous
honking we've actually decided to stay
back a bit because the situation inside
is somewhat volatile now you take a look
now and there seems to be fewer people
but it appears they may be making it a
bit closer to queen's park let's have a
look at what things look like
earlier
today
[Music]
it was a scene commuters were dreading
bloor street flooded with vehicles and
demonstrators holding signs and canadian
flags as they walked on boards to
queen's park i'm here standing for
everyone no discrimination no division
that's what i believe in really really
outrageous this just one of a number of
streets and highways closed down due to
the protests demonstrators are still
gathered in ottawa and say they don't
plan to go anywhere until they meet with
the federal government primarily the
prime minister here in toronto the
crowds grew throughout the day what i
worry about
is this is this series of protests for
the truckers um
has you know been so negative and so
closely associated with negative
factions of society
that in fact rather than it turning into
a citizen's movement um it may actually
alienate people trying to be truthful
many took aim at mainstream media
condemning news coverage
[Music]
[Applause]
i think the rest of the population is
watching this with with
pretty significant interest and concern
jeffrey devorkin says the attack on
mainstream media is coupled with a
breakdown in public trust due to
changing public health measures locally
federally and provincially so what we're
seeing is a lot of
disinformation being spread
sometimes deliberately sometimes
inadvertently but that's the problem
meanwhile those on the streets are
asking government officials for just one
thing we also do not want to get the
vaccine we should be respected
so these are some of the trucks that
made it to the corner of bedford and
bloor that's about as close as they have
gotten to queen's park at this point
bloor remains closed and really mark if
anybody is trying to come into the
downtown core this evening it's probably
best that you do not there is all kinds
of traffic down here blocked off roads
and it's quite busy and of course a lot
of different demonstrators here at the
end of the day it's really unclear how
long people are going to remain here but
toronto's police chief has made it quite
clear that he does not want to see a
repeat of what we're experiencing right
now at parliament hill mark all right
also seems very loud there right now
morgan that's global's morgan campbell
reporting for us tonight thanks a lot
and speaking of covet 19 here are the
latest numbers in ontario provincial
officials are reporting just under 2500
hospitalizations today that is a
decrease of almost a thousand from last
saturday and it's down 141 from
yesterday 501 patients are currently in
intensive care due to the virus 59 new
deaths were also reported today those
all occurring not today or yesterday but
over the last month
today's case count is 3204
although the actual number is believed
to be much higher due to testing
limitations in ontario for a full
breakdown of all the covet 19
information you need you can log on to
our website at globalnews.ca
you know there's a lot of other stories
in the news but
the vaccination effort goes on
meanwhile mayor john tory visited a
vaccine clinic at a toronto community
housing building in the west end of the
city tchc buildings have now hosted more
than 500 clinics since the vaccination
initiative started workers go door to
door approaching all tenants in each
complex to inform them about the
opportunity if people are unable to make
it downstairs to the clinic but water
for whatever reason but want a shot
staff and volunteers will bring the
vaccine to them
our objective has been to leave nobody
behind when it comes to the vaccinations
and that is why
as a city we have achieved the
extraordinary results we have and that's
thanks to the people that have got
vaccinated as well as the team
delivering the vaccines
now so far over 90 percent of
torontonians have received at least a
first dose of a vaccine just under 90
percent have been given two doses more
than 60 percent have received a booster
shot and 54 percent of children aged 5
to 11 have also got their shots
let's switch gears now and take a first
look at the forecast shall we for that
let's bring in weather specialist carla
bosaki hey carla
thanks mark well it was a gorgeous day
here's a look at the skyline right now
you can see the sun it is starting to
set minus nine is what we're sitting at
the winds now coming in from the south
southeast temperatures right now minus
15 in ottawa minus 14 in muskoka
kingston sitting at -11 this is what
it's feeling like out there ottawa
really is still dealing with that
bitterly cold air overhead there is
nothing overhead as far as clouds go as
you can see on our pinpoint radar our
lows tonight minus 10 in windsor london
toronto minus 12 peterborough minus 21
and minus 24 through the ottawa region
we've got some milder air on the way and
some gusty winds for your sunday your
seven-day forecast is ahead
all right thanks a lot carla
the protest in toronto as mentioned
earlier is not the only one today in
fact they are being held in solidarity
in many parts all across the country
including in ottawa where thousands
remain for a second weekend in a row
demanding an end to federal covet 19
measures global's mike trolley has the
latest from parliament hill
it's been a week since protesters took
to the streets and took the streets here
in ottawa residents who've been living
with the constant blaring of horns want
them gone but the protesters that remain
appear to be digging in bringing in
saunas and ice huts to stay warm
[Music]
it appeared for a moment their funding
would be cut off gofundme decided the
protests had morphed into an occupation
and froze the remaining 9 million that
had been raised within hours organizers
had another option a christian
fundraising site that gained notoriety
for raising funds for the protesters
that stormed the u.s capital by midday
they'd already topped a million dollars
the crowds aren't as big as they were a
week ago but the protesters that did
show up are steadfast in their beliefs
and well resourced mike drolie global
news ottawa